[Musique]
j'écris un livre voilà d'entraîner créé
en décembre
bon écoute ou vise pas la non mais non
dans notre ordinateur j'ai deux éditeurs
qui me rappelait aujourd'hui la 1000
arbres c'est la maison d'édition la plus
prestigieuse mais d'une très
impressionné par votre livre
distiller ali arrive pourquoi moi quand
je veux pas la sculpture depuis qu'on en
passe j'ai plein d'idées la paul valéry
dessiner une demi-heure avant d'écrire
rimbaud et prenait de l'opium
moi je les cibles et paca pas con tu
peux envoyer sa des éditeurs le mari est
vraiment trop con vraiment reconnaîtra
et iphone j'essaie de faire sortir les
doigts ce chercheur
je frappe on ne tient plus vite j'étais
tellement qu la littérature c'est pour
moi ça me rend dingue que les âmes et
volé mon art et j'aimerais vraiment que
tu lises à temps parce que c'est le
moment la série où on va comprendre
qu'est le tueur
j'ai écrit un livre il ya plein de gens
qui l'achètent ce qui est en soi très
bon truc
ouais c'est dans la casserole en fait du
coupage pas ça un peu à la télé là du
tout à ça va s'arrêter
tu m'offres la mode ou la chaîne
d'hôtels et où je peux pas je peux pas
être avec controlling crowds
on était bien comme on vivait avant
bordel non avant c'était simple je me
disais un truc à l'écouté faire une
photo deux cent cinquante mille
exemplaires vendus je crois que c'est
rien du tout on voit j'en ai plein
d'étoilés
travaux multiples le loup soit par board
absolument je vais mettre au bonsaï
japonais pour sap est claire non c'est
ça c'est publié jeudi
moi je suis hyper publié non les
ajustements ne trouve pas que la grosse
ou non grosse tête ah bah voilà tu vois
toi aussi tu le dis
[Musique]